so smartmatic has made good on its
threats and is suing fox news for 2.7
billion dollars in an epic epic
complaint
now how epic is this lawsuit well let me
read you one paragraph from this
complaint the earth is round two plus
two equals four joe biden and kamala
harris won the 2020 election for
president and vice president of the
united states the election was not
stolen rigged or fixed
these are facts they are demonstrable
and irrefutable them
are fighting words right there for
better or worse this is a complaint that
was designed to garner
attention smartmatic is suing fox fox
news lou dobbs maria bartiromo janine
pirro rudy giuliani and sydney powell
for collectively 2.7 billion dollars now
here's the thing that number is
completely ridiculous it has no basis in
fact it is designed to generate
attention
but attention this has generated and
smartmatic is trying to undo the damage
to its reputation that was brought by
all of these people this will go down in
history as one of the most epic
complaints you will ever see in a
lawsuit so stick around for more
analysis and subscribe
or i'll see you in court